[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut les terriens
salut les terriens bienvenue dans votre
tour du samedi soir bonsoir
4 terriens de choix avec nous ce soir
enora malagré
bonsoir
alors vous êtes la chroniqueuse vedette
de la célèbre émission deux des huit
touche pas à mon poste et vous avez
tellement de succès n'aura qu'on dit
plus la blonde à côtés de cyril hanouna
mais le vendeur de roses pakistanais à
côté des noms ramallah grandes lignes on
est vite plenel
alors vous avez le bon soir karachi
cahuzac bettencourt d'assaut c'est
mediapart qui sortent toutes les
affaires dans ce pays et pour aider les
autres à devenir eux aussi de bon
journaliste d'investigation
vous lancez la moustache et devis plenel
ça se passe très facilement tout le
monde peut en acheter cela m florian
philippot bonsoir
alors que rien n'est fini pour vous nous
direz ce soir que vous vous inquiétez
beaucoup de la montée du front national
dans les sondages parce qu'il faudrait
pas que ça monte trop et que vous soyez
obligés de gérer le pays quand même
ça commence bien la commune gentiment et
soan
alors samedi il est célèbre pour avoir
gagné la nouvelle star après avoir
chanté dans le métro parisien c'est
exceptionnel en général les gagnants de
la nouvelle star chômeurs métro
ont fait croître les acquis et gaspard
proust vaquero notre invité du samedi 20
heures ce soir pierre rabhi le petit
immigré algérien devenu le pape de la
décroissance un personnage exceptionnel
nous sommes ensemble jusqu à 20h25 avec
et gréement de fortune
[Musique]
alors vive le nail rebond soir
ed vie vous êtes le superman du
journalisme d'investigation
c'est médiapart qui sortent toutes les
affaires dans ce pays bien sûr jean
michel aphatie et m'a bien vous aider il
ya les répétitions du grand journal oui
il est très occupé alors le nouveau
dossier brûlant de médiapart c'est une
affaire politique énorme vous sauriez
sur le point de révéler que manuel valls
aurait été socialiste quand il était
jeune
[Applaudissements]
c'était incroyable c'est surtout un un
immigré qui a oublié ce que c'était
d'être immigré autre scoop de médiapart
vous auriez la preuve que jean marc
ayrault serait vivant ça je suis je
pense que la preuve on la voit là c'est
le seul qui est un peu tient bon celui
qui est silencieux et dont on peut se
demander s'il est vivant c'est françois
hollande alors sur le fisf abuse l'atome
avait pas voulu enquêter c'est trop
facile
non mais le fils fabius c'est le fils
fabius frais fait pas de politique non
nous on s'intéresse aux affaires
publiques pas aux affaires privées alors
la seule grosse affaire qui n'est pas
sorti c'est la liaison entre françois
mitterrand et christine bravo là cette
fois c'est elle qui a balancé sérieux
ouais alors on veut bien tout pardonner
un mitterrand pétain la francisque
bousquet les écoutes le rainbow warrior
mais bravo
vous saviez pas non cela dit je suis
vraiment je suis mauvais surtout c'est
que vous n'êtes pas médias vous devriez
faire mediapart people réécouter en fait
j'ai je propose je cherche quelqu'un
dans le club participatif de médias pain
j'ai trouvé le titre c'est un peu macho
je le veux dire je voudrais la plaie
chez le coiffeur et qu'on fasse le
people rigoureux avec les petits bruits
sérieux recouper tout mais y'a personne
pour faire la bravo elle a dit que ça
s'était pas vraiment vrai tout ça enfin
le revenu sur ses dires vous saviez pour
bravo et le maréchal pétain n'hésitez
pas
remarquez au début de son mariage
jacques chirac avait eu une aventure
avec bernadette
donc passons aux choses sérieuses mon
cher et de vie le pari de mediapart est
gagné il s'accompagne d'une rentabilité
à deux chiffres
et là c'est le drame
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le taux de tva que vous vous est
attribuée 2,1 pour cent celui de la
presse papier risque d'être porté à 19,6
par la commission de bruxelles non c'est
faux c'est faux actuellement même le
gouvernement français défends un
principe qu'ils défendent depuis 2009 le
président sarkozy la cour des comptes
les ministres de la communication les
parlementaires tout le monde le dit
neutralité la presse c'est
indépendamment du support donc médiapart
depuis le début avec tous les syndicats
professionnels défend légalité et la
transparence
nous ne touchons pas un centime des
aides de l'état pas un centime venue des
contribuables parce que ceux qui
s'arrogent ces avantages la sont ceux
qui touchent et les chiffres sont
publics maintenant l'express plus de 6
millions de dette directe par an le
monde 19 millions le figaro de monsieur
dassault dieu sait s'il a de l'argent 18
millions sur nos impôts par an mediapart
0 c'est nous qui avons mené la bataille
pour la publicité de ces chiffres il
était opaque et dernier point mediapart
on publie nos comptes chaque année on
est les seuls avec le canard enchaîné
vous connaissez les comptes de tous ses
journaux non vous savez combien il
touche comment leur combiné tout rien
donc nous on est clean alors elle vit la
force de médiapart c'est de refuser les
rumeurs et de chercher les preuves on va
donc faire une interview rumeur ou
preuve
[Musique]
nicolas sarkozy est innocent dans l'
affaire bettencourt aux rumeurs aux
preuves preuve que cette formule est
fausse ouais nous l'avons expliqué les
juges d'instruction ne sont pas là pour
dire si on est innocent ou coupable
c'est le tribunal qui le décide ils sont
là pour dire s'il y a des charges et si
elles sont suffisantes dans le cas de
monsieur sarkozy nous avons publié tous
les attendus ils ont dit oui il y à des
charges mais nous estimons qu'elles ne
sont pas suffisantes dacourt l'envoyer
devant le tribunal qui n'est pas
vraiment innocent et il n'est ni
innocent ni coupable il ya des charges
mais ne sont pas suffisants voilà chacun
juge kadhafi a financé la campagne
présidentielle de nicolas sarkozy en
2007 rumeur ou preuve preuves mediapart
l'a démontré à donner les documents bien
sûr françois hollande est incapable de
prendre des décisions rumeur ou preuve
non il prend des décisions et une pente
pas les bonnes
d'autres ministres cahuzac ont des
comptes en suisse rumeur ou preuve
probable mais pas prouvée mediapart a
été entravée sur ses investigations
après laffaire cahuzac part justement
des rumeurs les rumeurs vous savez à
quoi ça sert à faire dire ils sont en
train de chercher dans la direction et
du coup faire taire les sources vous
avez vu ce qui est passé sur la source
essentielle de la faire le banquier
condamin gerbier tenir en prison qui
avait plus rien non non il n'a pas dit
ça c'est pas vrai on la rapt et l'état
suisse la rapt et parce que il a tout
révélé est ce qu'il a révélé les juges
travaillent dessus mais on l'a mis au
trou au gnouf l'un est donc attention la
rumeur est une façon de tuer
l'information
serge dassault a acheté des voix à
corbeil essonnes rumeur ou preuve rv à
la puissance mille mediapart j'ai encore
des comptes il dit écoutez c'est pas mon
problème younès devez vous donner de
l'argent si vous ne la pas de lien c'est
pas de ma faute mais celle ci cède 1,7
million rendez compte un milliardaire
industriels fabricants d'armes sénateurs
patrons de groupes de presse qui pour
avoir ce statut d'élu
prend les quartiers populaires avec un
immense mépris parce que ses démons ou
on gagne avec monsieur dassault de la
main à la main plus que dans le trafic
de drogue et vous savez la suite quand
même c'est que quand on achète c'est
comme dans un polar et bien les gens tu
m'as redistribuer l'argent ah bah non
comme l'assassin mais qu'est ce qui se
passe bien on défouraille les gens qui
ont piégé monsieur dassault il y en a un
qui a eu trois balles plus sec
jacques vous l'aviez prévu
je suis à bord
enora malagré
[Applaudissements]
je connais personne d'autre au monde qui
s'appelle n aura ça fait marc
d'assouplissant mais fabien mère
nourricière en breton que c'est beau âge
alors je suis buzzer alors vous êtes
donc enora la révélation télé de l'année
comme quoi il ya encore de la place pour
des jolies blondes aux yeux bleus avec
des gros seins cc c'est rassurant merci
d'ailleurs maintenant quand on dit
laplante de des knicks et puis laurence
ferrari c'est vous
non quand même pas laurence reste la top
ou humaine
quelle humilité alors enora vous avez la
réputation de dire ce que vous pensez
mais rassurez nous est ce que vous
pensez vraiment ce que vous dites
normalement oui j'aurais d'éclat il ya
quelques temps que votre pire ennemi
c'était dechavanne s'est pas la
cellulite plutôt nous
elle allume tout le monde toute la
semaine sérieux mais ça va fabrizio des
grands matches et dechavanne en fait
vous dites c'est mon pire ennemi j'ai
travaillé chez lui c'était horrible et
toulouse-ii j'ai dit je la connais pas
et puis j'aime pas je n'aime pas le
droit de pas aimer les gens alors en
revanche concernant antoine de caunes
oui vous dites avoir eu envie de chialer
en le voyant interviewé nabila c'est pas
le fait que le grand journal soit 500
milles de plus que touche pas à mon
poste
non non non on est ravi ça marche le
grand journal c'est nos grands cousins
on est super content mais c'est vrai que
ça nous a un peu surpris qu'ils
reçoivent nabila en mai une mission
médias on parle de toutes les émissions
et la folie de canal la folie de
rodolphe belmer d'art appris qu'ils ont
c'est quand même de nous laisser dire
tout ce qu'on pense d'eux mêmes de ne
pas être tendre avec des émissions en
cuisine il ya aussi le patron de télé 7
jours qui bosse là bas thierry moreau
alors lui il espère avoir le prix albert
londres depuis qu'il a découvert que tf1
avait diffusé un épisode de dr house qui
n'était pas celui annoncé dans télé
poche
c'est pas il a besoin de la moustache un
parce qu'il ya plus de temps qu'à lire
sur la télé là alors enora vous dit tout
un vous dis que je suis sans filtre et
récemment vous avez des vous allez vous
étiez de bisexuelle j'ai une phrase de
woody allen pour vous le bi sexuel a
quand même deux fois plus de chances de
ramener quelqu'un quand il sort le
samedi soir mais tu es mais c'est bien
pour ça mais voilà c'est un appel
d'offres en fait mes
potes en galère non ça me semble
important de voilà de le dire ça peut
aider aussi déjà peu décoincé
vous non vous êtes avis je veux savoir
jusqu alors on va passer maintenant à la
vraie nora
enora
que pensez vous réellement d'enora
malagré la chroniqueuse de touche pas à
mon poste soûlante parle trop fort et
vous énerve elle m'agace sympa dans le
fond la dernière fois qu'elle aurait
mieux fait de fermer sa gueule est
normal à ce matin voilà
ce
qu'est ce que vous menez mais pas
physiquement chez nos rames à la grèce
et dans fait de voir ses murs de berlin
quoi mais avant qu'il se fait
8000 euros par mois vous pensez qu'elle
les veaux enora malagré mais surtout
qu'elle ne les a pas bien plus
[Applaudissements]
frais qu'à non non c'est alors enora
malagré ji beaucoup de mal des gens
pensaient qu'elle va faire carrière non
je pense pas pourquoi pas parce que je
pense que je fais chez trop de gens donc
on va tout faire pour que je fasse une
petite carrière mais c'est pas grave
mon métier c'est pas ma vie c'est pas
grave si ça dure palach profite vous
pensez qu'elle va se retrouver comme
toute sa famille dans un bistrot en
bretagne
probablement elle sera très heureuse
alors à 3 elle boira verra je vais te
les donne une âme ouais enora malagré
[Musique]
voilà c'est une appendicite et on se
retrouve à tapis pour discuter de
l'actualité de la terre a touché
[Musique]
commencement les terriers rebond soirée
théâtre
nous sommes toujours sur la terre en
compagnie de raymond robbe malagré
et visuelle
florian philippot et johan
swahn rebond soir
tu soutiens
je sais
alors soit vous êtes chanteur j'ai
l'impression vous sortez actuellement
votre troisième album intitulé sens
interdit vous êtes ancien vainqueur de
l'émission la nouvelle star et vous avez
commencé à chanter dans le métro
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
alors il faut donner convient un
chanteur dans le métro pour pas passer
pour un [ __ ] non mais sérieux au
sérieux bas c'est cool de appartient 50
centimes on est content à 50 cent du web
parce qu'une faille à vincent delerm qui
passeront mais trouve le ballon j'aime
bien il ya vincent delerm qui est passé
il m'a acheté et m'acheter une pièce de
deux euros et par contre dans le cas de
vincent delerm j'ai jeté dessus quoi un
bref que je me suis bon ça tu me lâches
10/10/10 que ce soit eu de karachi bah
ouais enfin souvent les gens ils donnent
de l'argent pour vous arrêtiez de
chanter en plus
alors c'est pas marrant parce que quand
on chante dans le métro la routine c'est
métro métro dodo non non pas forcément
c'était métro une heure par jour ouais
parce que sinon quand on dort dans le
métro c'est métro métro métro le wef
jamais dormi jamais dormi dans le métro
alors là le pire de tout en fait donc
quand on chante dans le métro c'est qu'à
lorànt deutsch toute la journée pour
raconter l'incitation aux gens il
s'ensuit
alors vous avez gagné la nouvelle star
en 2009 l'année où normalement c'est
camélia jordana qui devait l'emporter et
faire l'amour avec andré manoukian en
échange d'un album
ouais mais j'ai fait l'amour avec honda
mannequin
alors beaucoup de gens avaient téléphoné
pour vous à la nouvelle star pas
obligatoirement pour pour voter il
voulait juste signalé m6 qui avait un
mec l'eau chaude
après votre victoire leur manoukian a
déclaré c'était génial de voir des mets
mes fans de lui elle découvrait un mec
qui l auraient pas donner un euro dans
la rue mais elle était prête à lui jeté
leurs culottes sur scène c'est parfois
c'est dégoûtant
il ya des gens qui téléphonent pour
savoir s'ils peuvent vous offrir des
fringues
ce contrat moi j'aime bien bien bien
bien comme il est là fort chardy sont
fausses a dit ouais et bien cette phrase
alors ça a vu sortez votre troisième
album il s'appelle sens interdits avec
comme premier single me laissent pas
seul avec la demoiselle inconnu
évidemment tous les cons vous demande
qui c'est mais bon bref
on s'appelle camille vrai nom c'est
quelqu'un en fait c'est un peu une
l'équivalent féminin de moi qu'on aurait
compris que mon pass grillé alors c'est
un album plus positif que les précédents
un bar faut dire que le premier parlé de
la mort et le deuxième de la mort de
votre meilleur ami donc ça pouvait aller
plus positif c'est même plus que ma
meilleure amie c'était et
je suis sûr qu'elle est contente que je
sois là puisqu'elle vous aimez bien
aussi bon on regarde à quoi ça ressemble
[Musique]
retour sur l'eau
rien ne te dis
pas mal
[Musique]
émir
c'est
[Musique]
soit la somme mais n'est-ce pas seul
extrait de son dernier album sens
interdit
alors ce même ont besoin souvent
reproché à eric naulleau le premier
d'être un rebelle marketing on va voir
si c'est vrai ou si c'est faux on va
faire un trajet test
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors est-ce que vous avez déjà bu des
produits qu'ils se mettent
habituellement dans des moteurs
sa non non c'est parce que j'ai un
ulcère début du cern à rien il faut
faire attention est-ce que vous avez
déjà touché à la tri sexualité bah oui
mais non mais c'est plus marrant parce
que vous avez déjà frappé une fan
non ça c'est pas tracé coup ouais c'est
pas mal c'est vrai c'est un peu qu'on
ramène pas trop sinon je te parle de la
très sexy
[Rires]
et je vous ai déjà prostituées
si on veut je faisais hébergé par une
meuf qui a plus de deux mois en échange
de services quoi dire ouais d'une part
la prostitution ouais mais moi je suis
moi je m'en fous qui t'avait comme façon
quitte à briser une [ __ ] autant
qu'elle fasse un peu un truc utile
c'était pour la belle je rigole est-ce
que vous avez déjà porter un slip en
cuir non mais je passerais slip
ouais je sais est-ce que vous avez déjà
porter des menottes ailleurs que dans un
commissariat surtout au commissariat
mais ailleurs aussi web est-ce que vous
avez déjà fait des sex-tapes
oui il a tout fait moi qu'il est assez
trash quand même hein est-ce que vous
avez déjà su c'est le talon aiguille
d'une femme à non non ah bah écoute
ce soir
non mais j'ai d'autres idées est ce que
vous êtes déjà rasé tous les poils j'ai
tenté une fois mais ça me brûle ses
oreilles vous êtes déjà automutilée
ouais ouais alors en fait c'est à dire
qu'à un moment donné l'existence n'était
pas très supportable et que donc du coup
j'avais une aiguille pour le coup de
cuir et je me faisais ça d'un coup et
sur l'épaule parce que du coup ça calme
sa gamme tellement que d'un coup on n'a
plus envie de se coucher c'est vraiment
né vous êtes assez trash métal indus si
naulleau a tort
ça
florian philippot re bonsoir enfin vous
êtes vice-président du front national
vous êtes énarque êtes tout seul ou fn
être énarque nom avant plus maintenant
parce que sinon en cas de victoire vous
auriez été ministre de tout
alors vous habitez avant
chevènementistes et comment avez vous pu
vous retrouver au fn on vous a répliqué
votre pain au chocolat vous
non mais j'en suis très fier ça va faire
largement avoir été chevènementiste que
sarkozy s'est toujours gaulliste en fait
à moi j'ai toujours été gaulliste
d'accord puisque je suis venu au front
national pas rigoler parce qu'il sait
pas si c'est parce que je fais bien
voilà vous avez vous avez dans la tête
des idées fausses sur le front social
mais c'est pas de votre faute parce
qu'il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup de quatre
surveillants qu'avec vie est belle
saison beaucoup caricaturé aussi vous
savez pour savoir ce qu'est le front
national oui c'est comme une voiture
vous soulever le capot pour aller voir
si le moteur est bon il faut soulever le
syli peau
je viens alors soulevé la moustache et
vous verrez le militant le miracle
difficile de la sauver difficile de la
solide et le journal signale ni noah il
adore il avec conviction
bon on florian philippot vous avez été
l'artisan de la dédiabolisation du fn
c'est empêcher jean-marie le pen de
sortir de sa maison de retraite
non mais la dédiabolisation pourquoi
elle est finie ça y est on est dans
l'étape d'après un accord à l'étape
d'après c'est l'accession au pouvoir
d'un truc qui vous chagrine quand même
c'est quand on vous appelle extrême
droite vous dit le fn n'est pas un parti
d'extrême droite ils le savent les
militants ça
fait plaisir non mais non seulement ils
le savent et sont les premiers choqué et
peiné par sa voyez nous sommes
aujourd'hui défenseur de la nation art
c'est vrai que dans une petite caste
médiatico politique c'est pas très à la
mode la nation n'est pas la nation elle
pas là les idées patriote on préfère
l'union européenne on préfère
l'ouverture totale des frontières met
d'ailleurs économique migratoire
financière tout l'ouverture totale des
frontières à la marine le pen a accepté
à demi mots qu'on dise national
populiste non elle n'a pas accepté qu'on
dise ça je vous dis le but quand on dit
obligé de dire démago ou et on a compris
en même temps ça vous qu'on a un sacré
mépris pour le peuple vous appelez
comment alors vous avez une politique
patriotique national
que la gauche n'a pas vous avez une
politique sociale que la droite n'a pas
donc vous êtes socialiste et nationale
fait exactement la même démonstration la
grille mais personne ne le dit une
journaliste française leurs ergots t sur
le fait que vous soyez extrême droite ou
pas vous êtes socialiste national je
voulais déjà dit je vous ai pas bien ce
qu'il ya derrière ce thème ce cas
derrière et m'a été c'est pas c'est la
vérité je vous dire à ce moment là dit
ça du général de gaulle il avait une
politique économique et sociale
infiniment plus social que sale [ __ ] du
parti socialiste aujourd'hui qui est
ouvert à l'ultralibéralisme et il avait
une politique nationale où il défend des
analystes ça fait pas de lui un nazi et
devis un mot sur l'appellation comment
doit-on appeler le front national à
votre avis bien sûr que c'est une
formation d'extrême droite c'est une pme
familiale le front national les
révélations de mediapart sur le micro
parti de madame le pen elle prête
micro-partis algues vertes ou les us et
bien le léviathan c'est nous qui les
avons rêvé reparler dès que je dis
quelque chose c'est l'important monsieur
second m'interrompre à retenez bien ça
il s'appelle il s'appelle jeanne ce
parti j'avais ce qu'il fait il a prêté
quatre cent cinquante mille euros au
front national pour la campagne
électorale à quel taux tous ceux qui ont
des prêts bancaires 7% 7 7% est
imbattable et du coup 10 près de 20000
euros dans les caisses du micro parti de
madame madame le pen contre les
parasites à se faire le même florian
philippot il ya 180 adhérents dans le
micro parti madame le pen vous voyez ce
que ça veut dire il faut que les
militants du front national sache ça
c'est tous les copains c'est tous les
copains qui étaient avec madame le pen à
assas du goût des hôtes qui contrôle les
finances et enfin on en parlera tout à
l'heure telle est l'histoire de
l'extrême droite dans notre pays depuis
maurras depuis la fin du 19e siècle
c'est encore une fois dire aux français
ce mensonge vous avez des problèmes eh
bien on les résoudra en s'attaquant aux
étrangers les premières affiches du
front national vous vous en souvenez il
n'y avait pas beaucoup de chômeurs à
l'époque on disait leurs affiches était
tentant d'immigrés tant de chômeurs
supprimer les immigrés durera plus de
chômeurs c'est un mensonge ça fait 40
ans qu'on entend ça quarante ans qu'on
fait cette bataille contre l'étranger en
boucs émissaires ça a résolu nos
problèmes ça a résolu nos problèmes
d'europe nos problèmes de précarité nos
problèmes d'identité c'est un mensonge
total c'est une imposture total ça n'a
rien pu le résoudre puisque nous étions
jeunes au pouvoir mais les gens
s'amusent et les autres monsieur plenel
votre petit show c'est bien vous êtes
donner bonne conscience jedir les
conventions dans la machine quand je le
veux mais je débats des jeux veut dire
une sur le battez vous n'avez pas besoin
d'insulter les contingences zola est ce
que quand on nous dit vous êtes et ne je
vous assure que le plus haineux ici
c'est pas moi ça se voit jacquin les
téléspectateurs gênés alors apparemment
dans votre parti il ya des gens qui
savent pas encore que le parti n'est
plus un parti d'extrême droite comme
cette fille qui a traité christiane
taubira de singe elle savait pas elle a
été non mais c'est alors lui avait pas
dit nous avons mis trois heures pour
lescure je sais aussi que monsieur
bourdouleix qs a dit des choses
épouvantables à lui d i contre les roms
l'extermination hitler ils ont mis une
semaine pour l'exclure bien ce qu'on
peut dire c'est toute la presse vous
soutiens en tous les cas vous avez
vraiment cette presse-là c'est très vrai
cela la sedane en fait tiré pas dire que
c'est nous d'ailleurs qui mettons
maintenant les questions d'immigration
dans le débat non il les met regarder
ces derniers temps valls copé pourquoi
ils mettent les questions dans le débat
parce qu'il voit bien que c'est une
preuve d'une nation qui monte dans
l'électorat et qu' il essaie de s'ouvrir
après nos électeurs et c'est les vases
et les tiens mais vous venez de vous
griller tout seul alors que vos
électeurs wii sont les gens qui pensent
ça qui pend équipant son intégration
nationale qui pensent adore l'étranger
ces gens qui pensent à biscarrosse tiko
les générations
on va en parler
puisqu'on passe maintenant à l'actualité
de la terre avec l'édito de blacko et
c'est françois gemenne
spécialiste des flux migratoires que
nous retrouverons sur ce plateau après
le magnéto ce soir nous nous poserons la
question
immigration et si ce n'était que le
début
moi j pages pages c'est pas super
tube haïtienne après laffaire leonarda
qui a mis la france dans tous ses états
cette semaine c'est copé qui ajoute de
l'huile sur le feu les enfants nés en
france de parents illégalement installés
sur le territoire français ne peuvent
pas devenir automatiquement français
prennent et celle ci de l'hexagone
c'est parce qu'on fait en ce moment faut
dire qu'en ce moment la peur de
l'étranger un thème porteur dans
l'opinion
aujourd'hui 70% des français où il ya
trop d'étrangers dans nôtre pays moi je
trouve qu'il ya beaucoup trop de raciste
en france pourtant selon les chiffres de
l'insee la proportion d'étrangers en
france a baissé en 1982 les étrangers
représentaient 7 % de la population
française le seuil de tolérance il a été
atteint en temps plus tard les étrangers
ne représentent plus que 6 % de la
population mais curieusement - iliad
étrangers en france plus les français
trouvent que les étrangers sont trop
nombreux difficile de mettre en cause le
manque de fermeté des autorités
françaises il ya une dizaine d'années
sous jospin la france expulse et 9000
étrangers par an l'an dernier valse à
expulser 36000 personnes quatre fois
plus de monde
aujourd'hui les seuls immigrés qui
réussissent à nous émouvoir un peu ce
sont les naufragés de lampedusa c'est
pas l'homme qui prend la mer c'est la
mer qui prend l'homme
pour un peu on serait prêt à ouvrir
grand les bras pour tous les accueillir
mais bon faut être raisonnable comme
disait michel rocard nous ne pouvons pas
héberger toute la misère du monde ce
n'est pas possible désolé les gars c'est
pas de gaîté de coeur mais va falloir
qu'on repousse à la mer pourtant la
france est toujours prête à voler au
secours des opprimés la preuve hollande
était à deux doigts de bombarder bachar
el-assad pour sauver les victimes de la
tyrannie en revanche quand il s'agit
d'accueillir des réfugiés c'est une
autre histoire sur les 3 millions de
syriens qui ont fui leur pays la france
en a accueilli 500 pas mal sauf qu'en
suède alors qu'ils ne sont même pas 10
millions ils ont accueilli 17 mille
réfugiés syriens
alors forcément dans un pays qui a peur
des immigrés comme de son ombre quand on
parle des réfugiés climatiques
il ya de quoi se taper une bonne crise
d'angoissé
d'ici 2050 entre 200 et 500 millions de
terriens seront chassés d'endroits où
ils vivent à cause du réchauffement de
la planète on sent on devrait pas
paniquer
sur le long terme la vraie menace pour
l'europe c'est la crise démographique
sans l'apport de l'immigration d'ici
2060 l'union comptera 70 millions
d'habitants de moins qu'aujourd'hui ça a
l'air d'une blague mais bientôt le vrai
problème en europe ce ne sera pas qu'il
ya trop d'immigrés au contraire c'est
qu'il n'y en aura pas assez
voilà c'était les ghettos de blacko
mise en image de julien grave
françois gemenne bonsoir vous êtes
docteur en sciences politiques
spécialiste des flux migratoires
bienvenue parmi nous alors l'immigration
et si ce n'était que le début a
recommencé par l'afrique ils sont 1
milliards ils seront bientôt 2 milliards
il ya des guerres il ya des troubles
dans le sahel l'immigration africaine va
s'amplifier est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec le sénateur marini qui dit
on regrette kadhafi parce qu au moins
lui il avait signé un deal avec
berlusconi ce qui empêchait tout ces
gens là d'arrivée d'afrique vous êtes
d'accord avec marie n'est ce pas l'idée
de le regretter ou pas j'aurais
effectivement façon la situation
aujourd'hui avec les islamistes et la
charia au pouvoir et pas du tout
appréciable pour les libyens mais il est
vrai qu'il y avait des accords on sait
qu'ils avaient des accords et qui le
voilà il empêcher une immigration encore
plus massive vers l'union européenne
notamment vers l'italie pour être vous
savez il ya une déclaration universelle
des droits de l'homme qui a été adoptée
en 1948 dans l'article 13 et l'article
14 de cette déclaration universelle il
est énoncé deux droits fondamentaux de
l'homme
le premier c'est de pouvoir circuler
toute personne a le droit de circuler
librement et de choisir sa résidence à
l'intérieur d'un état et le deuxième
c'est le droit d'asile devant la
persécution toute personne a le droit de
chercher asile c'est un endroit pourtant
c'est le droit à l'immigration on dit
aussi toute personne a le droit de
quitter son propre pays et j'allais y
venir parce que c'est le propre de
l'homme c'est de pouvoir bouger arrêtons
d'avoir peur sous votre contrôle
actuellement je crois que c'est au
maximum 3 % de la population mondiale
qui vit hors de son pays de naissance au
maximum donc résolvons comment nous
affrontons ces problèmes comme en
discutons de ces problèmes mais arrêtons
de croire que l'on va non seulement
empêcher des gens de venir avoir peur de
40000 personnes à lampedusa quand on est
un continent de 600 millions d'habitants
françois l'afrique est ce que c'est un
réservoir d'immigration qui va se lancer
sur l'europe bien sûr et heureusement
aujourd'hui on a absolument besoin de
l'immigration africaine en france et en
europe partout ailleurs en 2011 sur le
territoire français il ya eu à peu près
260 5000 nouveaux immigrants à peu près
50 mille européen
une partie de ces immigrés étaient
naturellement des immigrés qui venait du
maghreb à peu près 30 35 % 10 %
d'afrique subsaharienne et dans le même
temps il ya eu deux cent mille français
qui sont partis ce qui veut dire que la
france se viderait si nous n'avions pas
l'immigration ben moi je fais exactement
inverse je voudrais que les français et
notamment les jeunes talents reste et
pour cela il faudrait relancer la
machine france parce qu'aujourd'hui
n'est pas très attractif c'est vrai et
puis pour le reste vous voulez quand
vous dites l'immigration massive qui
vient c'est vrai mais c'est pas le
projet des français ces projets du grand
patronat
c'est lui qui depuis la fin des années
60 a poussé à l'immigration parce que ça
fait de la main d'oeuvre bon marché
docile et ça je trouve que la gauche
notamment devraient se mortifier d'avoir
défendu ce projet parce qu'elle a donné
une caution morale
un projet qui est uniquement de fric et
c'est quand même de la main d'oeuvre qui
fait le travail que les français veulent
pas te voilà ça c'est un exemple on dit
ça pour pas parce que les français
seraient parés ce nom des français
veulent pas de taper le marteau piqueur
sages peuvent ou ne veulent pas se taper
la à ce prix là et dans ces conditions
là parce que c'est un moyen pour le
patronat ne pas augmenter les salaires
il sait qu'il a une réserve de main
d'oeuvre derrière qui s'appelle
d'immigration et son look
voilà donc nous améliorons palais
république c'est l'ascenseur social city
qu'il marteau piqueur c'est tout nouveau
c'était
avant c'était nous les bretons doivent
être les premiers migrants de
l'intérieur encore une fois désigné
l'étranger comme la cause de nos
malheurs faire simplement son personnel
c'est quasiment sûr il a dit s'en
remettre les propos de ce clip haut en
perspective l'immigration de travail en
france où le nombre d'entrées chaque
année ça représente à peu près 10% de
l'immigration ça représente à peu près
vingt mille personnes c'est pas beaucoup
dansé millions d'habitants un pays où il
est déjà 5 millions de chômeurs c'est
beaucoup ah ben voilà l'étranger
commençons par celui non c'est pas mieux
l'insa rennes le travail j'ai pas dit ça
l'impact des immigrés slam danse émoi
mais quasiment j'ai lu écrit et parlé
des salaires le niveau des salaires
augmentent légèrement du fait de
l'immigration c'est faux vous gagnez
c'est faux mais 0 27% en plus à cause de
l'immigration c'est faux il ya plein de
rapports qu'ils ont démontrée et si
c'était vrai je vous assure que le grand
patronat serait pas le premier défenseur
jeu quand le medef premier pour défendre
l'immigration je continue donc avec
l'extrême ans et en extrême orient s'est
réfugié climatique chaque le jour où il
y aura sado bangladesh ils seront
obligés de partir ils viendront ici
non mais enfin ce qu'on observe le mans
c'est que la plupart des migrants qui
doivent se déplacer à cause des
dégradations de l'environnement
milliards d'abord à l'intérieur de leur
propre pays simplement parce que souvent
les frontières sont fermées par
seulement au nord mais au sud aussi et
que aussi cette fois qu'on oublie
souvent ça coûte très très cher de
migrer et les populations qui sont
touchés par ces changements climatiques
sont souvent des populations très
vulnérable ça veut dire qu'elle bouge
souvent à quelques kilomètres simplement
et donc ce sont des migrations en fait
de très petites distances donc le livre
fameux livre de jean raspail le camp des
saints où on voit un million de gens
arrivés sur les côtes méditerranéennes
pour vous c'est de la science fiction
l'état actuel des politiques migratoires
aucune chance d'arriver d'accord alors
est ce que la france est la championne
d'europe de l'immigration légale
non ce n'est pas en france qu'il ya le
plus d'immigrés si on prend des pays
comparables en europe le royaume uni en
2011 a accueilli cinq cent cinquante
mille immigrés
l'allemagne 500000 l'italie 385 milles
et la france ensuite deux cent soixante
sept nains
vous saviez ça oui je sais mais c'est
pas une raison et alors oui d'accord
qu'est ce que la moitié des autres quoi
c'est quand même temps les discussions
quand vous écoute on a besoin d'eux on
touche ici non mais 267000 parents parce
que moi on dit toujours mais vous savez
ça s'est bien passé pour les italiens
les polonais ça je sais ma grand-mère
était polonaise mais ça s'est bien passé
mais les mais vous savez les flux
n'étaient pas les mêmes aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans une crise économique et
sociale gravissime il faut dire qu'ils
sont ses jambes soixante mille d'entre
eux ce sont des étudiants qui viennent
faire leurs études en quatre-vingt-dix
mille d'entre eux c'est du regroupement
familial c'est à dire les époux
étrangers des français la deux les
ordres en france qu'à vingt mille
immigrés qui viennent pour des raisons
humanitaires il y en a vingt mille qui
viennent pour des raisons économiques
florian vous dites que vous pouvez
ramener l'immigration de 200 1000 à
10000 est ce que c'est possible demain
il va dire ça serait
ça serait d'abord possible il faudrait
qu'un france hors de toute une série
d'accords internet au fait qu'elles
sortent des accords qu'elle revient à
dire qu'elle retrouve des frontières et
elle retrouve la maîtrise de sa
politique et non seulement d'immigration
mais pas simplement sa politique les
oeuvres à dire aussi que les français ne
pourraient plus une grève françois est
ce que l'immigration coûte plus qu'elle
ne rapporte selon les estimations elle
coûtera entre 4 et 10 milliards c'est
pas tellement les prestations sociales
vous dites si la gestion et la police la
justice l'administration on a parlé de
cette jeune fille qui était reconduite
au kosovo le coût annuel des reconduites
à la frontière ces 400 millions d'euros
une opération comme celle là par
personne ça coûte 21000 euros au
contribuable donc là de la politique
répressive a un coût énorme et puis si
l'immigration a un impact fiscal qui est
légèrement négatif et la france est une
exception d'ailleurs dans les pays
industralisés d'habitude les immigrés
rapportent de l'argent plus qu'il n'en
coûte en france il coûte un peu d'argent
c'est avant tout parce qu'on ne laisse
pas travailler alors on va conclure est
ce que la france peut accueillir toute
la misère du monde florian moi je suis
pour le couple assimilation républicaine
ouais la langue que ce soit des gens qui
deviennent ensuite français qui soit
pleinement heureux en france qui a un
boulot qu'un logement qui se sentent
bien qu'ils défendent des valeurs quand
je dis qu'on est enfin possible avec le
rythme actuel d'immigration qui a grandi
l'économie s'est dit c'est qu'il ya trop
d'immigration pour qu'on puisse
assimiler correctement tous les actes
philippot incarne la dérive des élites
françaises le poisson pourrit par la
tête ils veulent que les pauvres se
foutent sur la gueule quand les pauvres
se font la guerre les riches on la paie
et enfin je tien minh vous avez oublié
dans le sujet la suite de la phrase
c'est quoi ce mardi la france ne peut
pas accueillir toute la misère du monde
virgule mais elle doit en prendre sa
part dans son but mais on doit prendre
notre part c'est bien parce qu'un mot de
la fin en soi
sous d'avoir été avec nous enora merci
d'avoir été avec nous voilà c'était la
période où elle se trouve après la pub
avec le tapis gaz bar blues et notre
habileté du samedi 20 heures ce soir
pierre
titine et grunge à rien le mc de la
décroissance
à tout
[Musique]
laura bonsoir l'été à bromont soirée car
nous sommes toujours sur la terre en
compagnie d'elie bnl
nancy joue faux
soan et nous accueillons notre invité du
samedi 20 heures ce soir pierre rabhi
bonsoir
alors pierre rabhi au début des années
60 vous arrivé d'algérie est plutôt que
de vous abrutir dans un travail à
l'usiné pour pouvoir goûter aux joies de
la modernité la télé le frigo la machine
à laver vous décidez de vous installer
en ardèche dans une ferme sans eau
courante sans électricité un demi siècle
plus tard vous êtes devenu mondialement
célèbre ou publier des livres vous
donner des conférences ou fait des films
vous êtes pierre aujourd'hui le pape de
la décroissance et un terrien extra vous
nous raconter votre histoire à 20h dans
un instant gaspard proust mais d'abord
le zapping
c'était le zapping et j'accueille
maintenant gaspard proust pour elle est
pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
ça
ça fait du bien d'arriver sur assez
chaud tant d'amour partagé pendant une
heure
bon moi je vais pas parler les sujets
immigration tout ça non léonard da ah
non mais là la meuf la déstabiliser le
pays ouais ça eu des répercussions
terribles sur plein de secteurs juin
nabila ne dort plus oui
bon c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
contrairement à nabila qui a choisi les
paillettes leonarda a choisi l'école
ces normes alors quand même dû se rendre
compte que pour faire escorte n'était
pas gagné d'avancé
non mais moi en tout cas j'espère
qu'elles vont pas trop se tirer la
bourre parce qu'après une qui veut faire
le buzz autre que faire le con tre
baisse parce que nabila récemment a fait
ça en grand journal est là elle a montré
la écarté son antre cuisse et on a vu
son le toboggan à mioches qua
non mais il faudrait pas que léonard da
et la même idée je reçois déjà ces
images violentes de syrie toi
alors jean vincent placé a réagi c'est
le seul qui réagit c'est le seul qui a
fait on va faire des manifs de lycéens
pour manifester pour son retour bon
c'est un peu normal on sent que léonard
dallas tout d'une militante europe
écologie le sex-appeal de duflot la
syntaxe d'eva joly et la moustache de
noël mana
[Applaudissements]
attention je vois je vois que plenel me
scrute avec ce petit oeil mais que tu te
qui parce que mince mais pardon quoi ya
pas des sujets plus importants que de
stigmatiser les étrangers philippot
c'est un supporter cette quête du bouc
émissaire bonjour petit mouton de l'aïd
de voir l'autre comme un problème alors
qu'il peut être une solution
aux chutes attention bombe y traversent
le plateau
c'est une honte ardisson de ce qui se
passe de fouler aux pieds ces grands
principes que sont le droit du sol quand
je vois chez moi chaque jour ma femme de
ménage le lustre et avec passion
notre pays c'est un grand pays et on
peut faire des choses comme dirait je ne
sais plus si tu es sartre ou anna
gavalda mais ensemble c'est tout
à notre monde à nous sommes la
république pardon pardon le creuset
républicain ça existe la grande cocotte
nationale qui agglomère tout c'est pas
rien on pourrait pas se rassembler un
peu non mais tout le monde s'il vous
plaît pourrait pas un peu tout y est
aggloméré notre vivre ensemble dans la
fraternité il est temps que le peuple de
france seul il faut que les français
féculent
oui l'immigré c'est quoi c'est la
maïzena du lien social
on a tous vocation à être un flageolets
du grand cassoulet nationale je vous le
dis moi au
un bisounours qui mangent une compote
avec un lieu
est ce que ce sont vraiment les
étrangers qui sont responsables d'après
philippe au ces les étrangers qui sont
responsables des princes de la france on
veut nous faire croire que la famille de
léonard da abusé de la france que la
volée de travail pardon au contraire
elle en a donné à la caf au conseil
général
à manuel valls
à la police des airs à des boulots et
essaie dresse coupé de ce relais de
croissance
[Rires]
la coccinelle
moi quand moi quand je vois le périple
de cette famille qui affrontait les
dangers pour rejoindre la france de son
italie natale traverser les abruzzes la
plaine du pô les orques du pays du
mordor les dragons les agents de
saroumane legris l'oeil de schengen qui
voient tous qui surveille tout
et ils ont évité jusqu'à l'arrivée dans
12 pays des hobbits voilà
je je sais pas encore si c'est oui c'est
ça c'est une licorne qui accouchent
nous le pays de hugo on se refuserait à
accueillir des petits thénardier
les noms mais s'il vous plaît les dix
branis sont innocents voilà une famille
qui a toute sa place en france à la télé
aussi mais pas la rubrique faits divers
mais dans une famille en or
ou une famille en cuivre
il faut être sérieux
alors on peut se poser peut-être une
seule question la seule question que
personne n'a posé ces gens qui viennent
pour intégrer un pays plus riches qui
veulent offrir à leurs enfants des
meilleures écoles qui veulent gagner
plus d'argent pour progresser
socialement et montrer au pays d'origine
qu'ils ont réussi la seule question que
je me posais mais est ce que la france a
les moyens d'accueillir tous ces gens de
droite
[Applaudissements]
mais passons à autre chose international
les usa espionne toujours et encore la
france tu m'étonnes avec la sphère
leonarda dans un monde aussi dure et
triste quand même dommage pour les
américains de se priver de telle barre
de rire
maintenant qu'ils ont été découverts les
américains tremble ah oui quelles vont
être les représailles parce que hollande
va
interdire la parade de mickey oui
expulsé mac ronald du territoire proposé
à une fille obama de venir étudier en
france mais sans ses parents je sais pas
cocasse un iranien condamné à mort
survit à sa pendaison alors maintenant
c'est vrai à la mort qui parle qui
respirait encore c'est non ce qui est
inquiétant
ça fait 40 ans que l'occident se fait
menacer par un pays qui ne sait pas
faire un noeud coulant oui
[Rires]
pour toujours bertrand cantat affirme
j'ai commis l'irréparable pourquoi il a
fait un duo avec la fouine
[Applaudissements]
détendre un peu l'atmosphère un chinois
a tué sa soeur à coups d'haltère oui bah
c'est le fitness à la chinoise ce que tu
fais un exercice tu perds 55 kg
bonne nouvelle au cinéma sorties de
gravity donc j'ai l'histoire de deux
individus qui n'évite dans leur bulle au
dessus de la réalité en france on a la
version longue elle dure cinq ans mais
voilà l'aline
pour elle ce matin
je suis là demain à 15 heures
et bien sûr sur canalplus.fr terriens
vous aussi vous pouvez suivre l'actu de
l'émission réagir sur twitter via le
conflit terrien et le hashtag slt on
passe maintenant à notre invité du
samedi 20 heures
[Musique]
pierre rabhi rebond soir vous êtes né le
29 mai 1938 à kenadsa une oasis
algérienne aux portes du sahara va votre
père était forgeron votre mère est femme
au foyer et votre maman meurt quand vous
avez quatre ans et vous n'avez même pas
une photo d'elle c'est terrible de pas
avoir d' image
oui parce que nous avons besoin de nous
situer au devoir que les lettres qui
nous a mis au monde et qu'on a la
sensation d'être clandestins parce qu'on
n'a pas connu la l'être humain la
personne la femme qui vous a donné la
vie alors la mort de votre mère votre
père en douce le rôle de maman auprès
des cinq enfants du couple il épouse une
autre femme et donc il reconstitue le
foyer mais on est dans une configuration
différente à votre père c'est un
forgeron mais il jouait du luth et jouer
du violon il écrivait des poèmes vous
dites c'est une divinité pour moi oui le
souvenir que j'en ai évidemment c'est
c'est un être d'exception alors au début
des années 40 votre père est obligé de
travailler dans les mines de charbon
exploités par des entreprises françaises
tous les soirs il rentre à la maison
couvert de poussière noire et la du
noble forgeron vous ne voyez finalement
qu'un homme a servi par le par le
système est ce que c'est de là que naît
votre insoumission je pense que oui
parce que la notion d'aliénation entre
un homme libre forgeron qui fait chanter
l'enclume qu'il soit chante réjouit les
autres à nîmes etc et qui finalement
fini par devenir quelqu'un qui rentre
tous les soirs soulier de charbon
je pense que cette image du jour disons
que cette cette anecdote n'est pas
anodine dans les choix que je ferai plus
tard alors pour vous assurer un avenir
plus doux à l'âge de 6 ans votre père
vous confier un couple de français il
veut que vous ayez ne savoir des
européens pour vous préparer à affronter
le monde moderne c'est un incroyable
sacrifice de se séparer de son enfant
pour son bien mais c'est aussi une
preuve d'amour alors vous êtes donc
accueilli par ce couple de français
catholique sans enfant lui est ingénieur
elle est institutrice vous découvrez la
brosse à dents mais pas que ça et là
vous commencez à vous poser des
questions qui a raison est ce que c'est
la tradition est ce que c'est là la
modernité vous commencé très jeune à
vous intéresser aux philosophes parce
que ce sont ceux vers lequel on va pour
essayer d'avoir une réponse aux
questions fondamentales que nous avons
alors vous venez de fêter vos 15 ans
quand votre père adoptif et lutter à
oran ensuite à 750 km de chez vous vous
hésitez à partir évidemment à quitter
votre votre région mais là votre père
biologique tranche il vous dit vous y
allez mais il le faisait encore une fois
je n'ai jamais voulu parce qu'il le
faisait avec l'un third pas dans une
intention d'amour et d'un art agréable
amour en bien soir seulement et ça a été
du très difficile très dur on a vous dit
tout les amarres sont rompus à partir de
ce moment là seulement alors à ce moment
là vous commencez à vous intéresser aux
évangiles et et vous est bouleversée il
ya de quoi évidemment par le message
d'amour de jésus-christ aimez vous les
uns les autres c'est une vibration une
puissance que chaque être humain en lui
et qui représente véritablement une
énergie à vous décidez de vous convertir
au christianisme
vous passez votre temps à la cathédrale
d'oran oui vous êtes vraiment vous
servez là mais tu sais mais vous
n'arrivez pas en parler à votre famille
quoi
c'était que je pouvait paraître un peu
comme quelqu'un qui aurait trahi y
voyant que vous ne retournais plus haut
village votre père biologique décide de
venir à oran et là il vous découvre
impeccablement habillés avec des gants
verts frais à la main parce qu'elle est
pas comporter les les gants à la main
vous allez au théâtre à l'opéra vous
héritez de la musique classique je suis
en train de devenir véritablement un
petit un petit occidentale 1 alors ce
jour là me perds vous demande de rentrer
mais vous ne rentrez pas oui et je
prends une option définitive parce que
je ne pouvais pas être écartelée enlevé
mais de culture c est la clé car
tellement on peut pas tenir longtemps
l'écartèlement vous restez vous ne
reverrez plus jamais votre père vous
n'irez pas à l'enterrement un non même
pas en 1958 en pleine guerre d'algérie
un jour vous êtes avec votre père
adoptif en train d'écouter à la radio
une allocution du maréchal juin et là
c'est pas trop pourquoi vous faites
remarquer avec père adoptif que le pari
challes juin à une voix un peu féminine
et l'autre un gaulliste de la première
heure qui étaient menacés de mort
d'ailleurs à l'époque pour des raisons
politiques il réagi très violemment très
très violemment il vous dit demain je ne
veux plus te voir à la maison et vous
vire réaction tout à fait rationnel mais
que j'ai compris parce que c'était qu'un
gaulliste effectivement
inconditionnel au milieu de deux du
monde de l' os etc
sa voiture avait été plastiqué ils
étaient menacés de mort et j'ai compris
que ce qu'on appelle la goutte qui fait
déborder le vase ensuite on entre dans
un monde complètement justement dans
cette et rationalité pierre est ce que
vous lui avait pardonné à tout à fait
alors vous prenez un paquebot pour la
france devrait à paris en 1959 vous
devenez ouvriers spécialisés à la someca
et là alors vous découvrez l'entreprise
ou et la hiérarchie les horaires fixes
les pointeuses c'est là où la
fréquentation des philosophes vous amène
à vous interroger finalement sur les
différentes conjonctures et moi ma
conclusion c'est est que l'homme était
aliéné par la modernité et que donner
donner toute sa vie en échange d'un
salaire moi ça ne me convenait pas du
tout et je considérais que ma vie valait
plus qu'un salaire et quand on parle de
l'aliénation c'est à dire de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler un itinéraire
d'incarcération de l'être humain et la
l'image que j'ai trouvé c'est à dire que
de dire écoutez il y as incarcération
puisque de la maternelle à l'université
on est enfermé dans un bahut ensuite
tout le monde travaille dans des boîtes
des grandes boîtes des petites boîtes
etc même pour pour s'amuser on va en
bois on y va comment dans sa caisse et
puis à la boîte à vieux en attendant la
dernière boîte que vous sont fines et
voilà bon c'est quand même dans cette
entreprise que vous avez rencontré
l'amour en la personne de michel et
c'est là que en 1961 en pleine période
des trente glorieuses
vous décidez d'aller à contre-courant de
l'exode rural l'exode rural c'est jean
ferrat la montagne un bon voilà et vous
allez vous installer en ardèche avec
michel mais en 61 c'est à dire sept ans
avant les utopies de 68 qu on libérait
tout ça je vais retourner à la terre et
je vais me rapprocher des sources de la
vie c'est à dire la nature et comment je
vais faire un bain je vais devenir
paysan voilà alors vous décidez de vous
installer en ardèche et quand vous
découvrez l'agriculture
ardéchoise vous est effondrée par
l'utilisation des engrais vous dites on
est dans une guerre chimique contre la
nature et on était dans cette ambiance
dance de poison poison que l'on met dans
la terre avec les engrais chimiques
poisons clan répond sûr dans
l'environnement donc on n'était pas dans
une voie qui me convenait puisqu'ils
n'étaient pas venus pour déclarer la
guerre à la vie
voilà nous intéressait désormais à
l'agroécologie
c'est-à-dire traiter la terre avec
l'humus enfin en la préservant la
respectant sur tout et vous découvrez ce
que vous appelez la sobriété heureuse
qui est une espèce de morale pour vous
finalement au début vous êtes obligés de
faire plein de petits boulots
heureusement on fait des fromages ça
vous aide quand même beaucoup et puis
après 68 les idées changé beaucoup de
stagiaires comment ça vous découvrir à
venir du monde entier et la ferme
commence à un marché cet agrès écologie
faisait l'exporter en afrique au burkina
faso vous partez souvent vos enfants
regrette un peu de ne pas vous voir
enfin c'est pour la bonne cause mais
vous partez quand même voilà et en 2002
vos amis vous pousse à vous présenter
aux présidentielles
et là vous parler de décroissance une
civilisation dites-vous de la modération
et aujourd'hui on affirme tout le monde
affirme que l'agro écologie la seule
façon de doré de résoudre le problème de
la faim dans le monde nourrir tout le
monde bien sûr yoris à l'agroécologie
peut nourrir absolument tout le monde le
nord le suit partout partout l'écologie
prend en compte le fait que rien ne se
crée rien ne se perd tout se transforme
donc elle entretient la vie d'un côté on
a une agriculture qui produit est
détruit et ne peut pas produire sans
détruire et de l'autre côté vous avez
l'agroécologie qui produisent non
seulement sans détruire mais régénère
comme je lé fais au sahel avec des sols
difficiles et rapide la terre finalement
c'est à dire chaque fois qu'un paysan et
formés à cela et bien il participe à la
régénération des sols à la régénération
d'environnement alors avant de se
quitter j'oserais dire vous êtes aussi à
l'origine du mouvement des colibris et
les jo et que nous racontions l'histoire
des colibris aujourd'hui vous savez très
bien qu'on est dans une espèce de
marasme dans les incertitude totale par
rapport au futur est dans cette
situation là aussi dit alors très
souvent on dit bah c'est l'état c'est le
si la politique c'est je sais par quoi
qu'irresponsable boxer en permanence et
j'ai eu la chance donc de tomber sur un
petit conte amérindiens qui dit qu'un
jour il ya eu un grand incendie de forêt
tous les animaux étaient atterrés
décourager et c est le petit colibri ce
petit oiseau tout gracile tout presque
insignifiant mais très beau lui il va
prendre quelques gouttes d'eau dans son
bec il les jette sur le feu et ils
s'activent le tattoo qui est la leur
garde depuis un bon moment et rudy
colibri une image quand même pas que
c'est avec ça que tu va éteindre le feu
il regarde en face il lui dit je le sais
mais je fais ma part voilà je fais ma
part parce que le mot de la fin je
rappelle le titre du dernier livre qui
vous est consacré
pierre rabhi semeur d'espoir entretien
avec olivier le naire chez actes sud
merci d'avoir été avec nous ça nous fait
du bien
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'était salut les terriens
d'autres 30 du samedi soir avec enora
malagré et qu'on retrouve dans touche
pas à mon poste et sur virgin radio tous
les soirs à 21h30 plenel directeur de
mediapart
florian philippot vice président
front national merci d'avoir été avec
nous soan
l'album s'appelle sens interdit et le
signal ne laisse pas seuls merci
françois gemenne de 40 sciences
politiques et pierre rabhi summer
d'espoir chez actes sud
rendez vous ici la semaine prochaine et
d'ici là sur canalplus.fr salut les
terriens
les corrections de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu